université alternance ou encore école de
commerce ou d'ingénieur plus de 80
exposants répartis dans une douzaine de
secteurs étaient réunis au palais des
congrès de versailles
un salon de l'étudiant destinée
néanmoins un large public
les parents sont de plus en plus
nombreux sur les salons à venir
accompagnés
les lycéens donc il faut savoir qu'on a
beaucoup de lycéens dès la seconde qui
recherche avant des informations sur
leur orientation post-bac
mais nous avons également des étudiants
de bac + 1 à bac ou cinq qui reçoit les
informations sur leur poursuite d'études
là les choix vont se faire rapidement
donc on essaye quand même de les guider
sans être trop sans leur mettre trop la
pression après des recherches
d'informations sur leur orientation il
sera temps de faire un choix pour les
élèves de terminale à partir du mardi 22
janvier tout se passera sur le site
parcours sup lancé l'année dernière la
plateforme nationale d'admission postbac
suscite encore quelques inquiétudes
ce que j'entends dire c'est vraiment
très compliqué il y en a qui ont
toujours toujours rien eu apparemment ça
fera chaud ça m'a fait très clairement
avec mon entourage
on l'a vécu l'année dernière c'est un
peu déstabilisant et la raison aussi
pour laquelle on leur dit de bien
travailler pendant ces années là les
futurs étudiants auront jusqu'au 3 avril
pour formuler et confirmé leurs voeux
les premières réponses il faudra
patienter jusqu'au 15 mai
[Musique]